this Sunday is Father's day and it's a
particularly big one for me it is my
first as a dad as you all know my wife
Marin and I welcomed our daughter Celine
earlier this year and she has brought so
much joy and purpose to our lives
I know as well as many sleepless nights
so as we celebrate fathers this uh this
weekend I visited our family's favorite
New York City neighborhood hangout it's
called nobody told me it's on the upper
west side and it is where we first
announced to our families on that day
that we were having a baby and I wanted
to share a letter with Celine about how
she's changed our lives in the most
beautiful ways
friends
[Music]
I was first asked to write a few words
about Father's Day as a first-time dad I
thought
what do I know
what can I possibly have to say I've
only been a dad for about four and a
half months I'm just learning it felt
like being asked to climb Mount Everest
when I was still at base camp just
putting on my boots but then I realized
something
[Music]
a little over 19 weeks which means
Celine your mom Marion and I have been
your parents for about
735 hours I have been your dad
44 100 minutes
the point is that from the very first
minute you came into our lives until
this very moment and even before I've
been your dad
Papa
I was there when you took your first
breath
and you were only seconds old when I
kissed you and whispered your name into
your itty bitty ear
Celine
from the Latin Colinas meaning Heavenly
must be missing an angel
and you were just a few hours old when
we had our first daddy-daughter dance
fittingly to Heaven Must Be Missing an
angel
those lyrics
missing one angel child cause you're
here with me right now
yes Celine in just four months you've
realized that your Papa loves music and
spends hours singing and playing for you
everything from Bach to Springsteen to
Coltrane
[Music]
and I can tell that you love it too
especially when I sing your favorite
song in Mandarin Chinese or at least I
try okay
we read together books in English books
in French and then Mama reads to both of
us in Mandarin so we both learn together
we go on walks to the park and we search
for birds and smell the flowers and
sometimes we do nothing at all
and just when I think that my heart is
filled to the brim with love and
devotion you go and do something you
grin at me in the morning when I peer
into your crib you grasp at something
you cry and you reach for me and guess
what my heart grows yet again
but I had learned something on this my
first Father's Day
it's one that I guess all dads and moms
too have learned
can't be taught
you can't prepare for it because the
only way to know it is to feel it
experience it
to live it
the feeling that a heart's capacity for
love is infinite
Limitless
Without End
dads know what that means
and now
for the very first time
so do I
[Music]
uh uh Hey that before before you say
anything let us just pause and say that
was a really powerful well done I mean
you carry that off gorgeously and I
could see you really in the moment there
as you were delivering it
um
yeah I mean watching it now and and
seeing all those images even though I
know I provided them and I've been there
for all of those moments um the only
thing I can say I mean I will say to you
Celine
or I need Daddy loves you
um yeah that I I have no other you guys
know you know you're a mom uh you and
Brian I this is his second Father's Day
um you guys have gone through many
father's days and I was very
apprehensive when our bosses were like
would you like to write an essay about
uh being a dad and I just thought I mean
I know we did Vlad to Dad for a couple
of months coming into this but it just
felt like there was still and I know
that there will be many challenges ahead
and so but yeah this was a really cool
exercise so thank you it's funny you can
you can grow up being taught what the
heart is medically you know then you
have a child and you realize this is the
personification of my heart in human
form walking around
on the earth I never knew that my heart
could live outside of my body and that's
what being a father is and that's why
it's so special and I see every day you
walk around with that pride of being a
new father you're doing a great job by
the way thank you it happened so fast I
mean she was all flat it she was you
know she's still a baby and you already
you know you feel like you've been her
father for so long even before she got
here yeah
I'm not gonna say anything anymore it's
so hard to be present for these things
and you're so present and that is a
lesson in of itself you're a fantastic
job and that yes as fathers we want to
tell you that thank you I love that